[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
zone Europe sur sensation
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro de zone Europe sur Radio
sensation et sur TV 78 cette semaine
nous partons sur les bords de la
Baltique à Riga en Lettonie ce pays qui
compte près de 2 millions d'habitants et
membres de l'Union européenne depuis le
1er mai 2004 la Lettonie a adopté l'euro
le premier janvier 2014 suite à la chute
de l'URSS la Lettonie proclame à nouveau
son indépendance en 1990 le pays fait
ensuite le choix de se tourner vers
l'ouest et d'adhérer à l'OTAN en 1999
mais la culture russe est encore très
forte dans le pays un tiers des
habitants ont cette langue comme langue
maternelle ici même à Riga ce chiffre
monte jusqu'à 50%
[Musique]
depuis la guerre en Ukraine les tensions
entre la partie russophone et la partie
Layton ce sont ravivés mais pour
comprendre d'où viennent ces frictions
regardons un peu en arrière j'ai
rendez-vous avec ginspal un historien
spécialiste du nationalisme laiton
bonjour guinzapals bonjour Monsieur
Merci de nous recevoir ici au musée de
l'occupation de la Lettonie un lieu
emblématique qui retrace l'histoire du
pays alors la première fois que la
Lettonie est devenue indépendante
c'était en 1920 avant elle faisait
partie de l'empire russe comment est-ce
que le nationalisme laiton est né
a déclaré son indépendance en 1918 mais
vous avez raison ce n'est qu'après deux
ans de lutte pour l'indépendance période
que nous appelons la guerre
d'indépendance de la Lettonie que la
Lettonie est devenue véritablement un
pays uni et libre en 1920 quand vous
posez la question de l'histoire
politique du pays avant cette période il
faut bien comprendre qu'il a fait partie
intégrante de l'Empire russe en réalité
pour une durée relativement courte
historiquement le premier état établi
sur ce territoire a été créé au 13e
siècle par des missionnaires européens
croisés et commerçant sous le nom de
l'ivoni la Livonie couvrait alors le
territoire correspondant à la Lettonie
et à l'Estonie actuelle cet état en
réalité une Confédération a existé
pendant trois siècles avant d'être
morcelé par l'invasion du tsar russe
Ivan le Terrible puis démembre et à
nouveau pour devenir la propriété de la
République des Deux Nations et à
l'Empire suédois
sur cette base historique la Livonie a
été divisée en trois provinces quand
nous parlons de la Lettonie actuelle la
moitié du territoire la partie ouest
intégrée l'Empire russe seulement
1795 et plus important encore jusqu'à la
fin du 19e siècle les provinces
baltiques ont conservé une autonomie
significative pour leurs affaires
internes et leur vie politique on peut
donc dire que le territoire Léton a été
absorbé pour devenir parti intégrante de
l'État russe seulement vers la toute fin
du 19e siècle conservant ce statut
pendant environ 3 décennies
[Musique]
et ensuite jusqu'en 1940 la Lettonie
était une république avant que les
troupes soviétiques reprennent le pays
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
comment est-ce que les laitons ont-ils
vécu cette deuxième guerre mondiale
la Seconde Guerre mondiale est bien
évidemment la période la plus
douloureuse de l'histoire l'étonne si
nous prenons en compte les victimes de
l'occupation soviétique et nazis la
population du pays qui était de 1,9
millions d'habitants en 1939 c'est
réduite de 500 000 habitants environ 250
000 laitons ont perdu la vie pendant la
guerre y compris la majorité de la
communauté juive et 250000 autres se
sont vus privés de leur patrie pendant
une longue période emprisonnée ou
déportée dans des terres lointaines de
l'Union soviétique ou encore forcée de
se réfugier en Europe de l'Ouest et il
restait pendant des décennies
et comment ensuite le nationalisme
laiton s'est-il manifesté pendant
l'occupation soviétique
quand nous parlons du nationalisme
laiton ce qui constitue un prérequis
pour fonder et construire un état nous
fixons son émergence vers la moitié du
19e siècle la création de l'État laiton
en tant que tel et le résultat du
mouvement nationaliste ce mouvement
était bien sûr etatiste dans sa forme
car quand l'occupation est exercée par
des forces étrangères cela conduit à
l'émergence d'un nationalisme non
seulement englobant la survie du nation
d'une identité d'une langue ou de la
liberté mais aussi du rétablissement de
l'indépendance Layton cela constituait
d'ailleurs l'objectif final de tous les
mouvements de Résistance pendant la
gouvernance soviétique et nazi
puis ensuite l'indépendance et en 1993
l'ouverture l'inauguration de ce musée
de l'occupation de la Lettonie quel est
le but de ce musée à l'époque des
méchants
principales d'abord pour se souvenir des
victimes ensuite pour commémorer le mal
infligé à notre territoire et au peuple
par des pouvoirs étrangers et enfin pour
faire découvrir notre histoire au monde
entier voilà pourquoi les visiteurs et
touristes étrangers sont les bienvenus
ici d'ailleurs la plupart de nos
visiteurs sont des touristes étrangers
qui visitent la Lettonie nous invitons
aussi tous les touristes français qui se
rendent à Riga à venir dans notre musée
et pour finir vous en tant qu'historien
j'imagine que c'est un lieu spécial pour
vous ce musée de l'occupation de la
Lettonie
sachez qu'un journaliste du New York
Times a récemment décrit ce musée comme
un sanctuaire national nous essayons
donc de maintenir la mémoire collective
du peuple laiton qui fait également
partie de notre identité dans le 21e
siècle et ses significatifs en ce moment
où la situation internationale est si
difficile notre but est simple rappeler
ce qui s'est passé pendant les
occupations autoritaires des forces
étrangères mais aussi expliqué pour le
futur ce qui a motivé des gens à lutter
pour l'indépendance et la démocratie
merci beaucoup ginsapal d'avoir été avec
nous
je rappelle que vous êtes donc historien
spécialiste du nationalisme laiton
[Musique]
nous l'avons vu les dissensions entre
les tons et russes ne date pas d'hier
mais depuis le conflit en Ukraine la
menace du nouvel invasion entre les
esprits c'est dans ce contexte que les
laitons ont élu en octobre 2022 leur
nouvelle Assemblée nationale une
élection remportée par le camp pro
occidental dorénavant comment sera
traiter la partie russophone j'ai
rendez-vous avec le nouveau président de
la seyma Edvard mintens
zone Europe sur sensation
bonjour Edvard Multon bonjour Monsieur
Merci de nous recevoir ici à la saima le
Parlement laiton qui a fêté donc en 2022
c'est 100 ans après l'indépendance de la
Lettonie dans les années 90 vous avez
fait le choix le pays a fait le choix de
se tourner vers l'Union européenne et
diabète en 2004 quel est votre vision de
l'Union européenne qu'est-ce qu'elle
représente pour vous
oui bienvenue au Parlement de Lettonie
bien sûr
on a on a gagné l'indépendance
et on a fait les routes vers les robes
l'automne vers les valeurs de l'Europe
et ce sont les valeurs de liberté de
démocratie et de indépendance
ce sont les valeurs qui sont
en danger maintenant parce que on sait
qu'est-ce qui se passe le crime et
maintenant on doit être unis et défendre
les valeurs qui qui sont le base de
l'Europe et qui sont les bases de
Lettonie aussi alors justement depuis le
début de l'attaque russe en
Ukraine on a un peu l'impression vu de
France que l'Union européenne est plus
soudée plus unique qu'auparavant depuis
le début vous soutenez vous la Lettonie
soutient progressivement elle fait
partie des pays qui soutiennent le plus
l'Ukraine vous possédez 300 km de
frontières avec la Russie on l'a vu donc
juste avant au musée de l'occupation
vous avez déjà été annexé deux fois par
votre grand voisin est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous vous sentez à nouveau en danger
vous savez nous avons je dis pendant
longtemps qu'est-ce qui se passe avec la
luce et nous sommes nous aimons
l'histoire avec avec la Russe
la russe ne change pas elle fait tout le
temps le même chose et c'est le dire on
doit être unis pour défendre notre
valeur on doit être totalement unis pour
défendre maintenant le crime parce que
le créne
défend maintenant l'Europe et ce qui se
passe le crime c'est quelque chose
énorme je ne pouvais pas imaginer que
c'est possible dans le dans notre siècle
dans notre moment donc
cette situation en fait beaucoup pour
une efficace de l'Europe et aussi pour
l'unification de l'automne je pense que
les décisions de Finlande et la Suède le
suède ce sont historiques le Suède
qui ont fait la demande
c'est à dire c'est sont les décisions
historiques maintenant et c'est fait
notre région l'Europe le Town plus
durable et plus possible de défendre
notre valeur maintenant donc et c'est le
moment que il y a justement blanc et
noir c'est à dire quand la guerre a
commencé à 24 février je n'ai pas dormi
le minutes j'ai commencé à réagir de
faire toutes les choses
dans mon poste avec mes collègues et la
Lettonie était les premières pays à
l'Europe qui a fait déjà
c'était le 30 prier on a commencé les
actions pour supporter le créne nous
sommes été les premiers qui est levé les
deux rapports de l'Ukraine à Riga et
justement
après c'était les
février le président de l'Ukraine
il a demandé pour tout ce que il doit
lever le drapeau comme symbole de de
support
de l'Ukraine on a fait déjà ça avant et
on a commencé la semaine le support de
le créer
on a fait le grand manifestation en face
de l'ambassade de russe et maintenant
lettonisme nous sommes le plus grands
contributeurs si on compte de notre
économie combien d'habitants on a
maintenant nous sommes le plus grand
contributeur de toutes les secteurs de
de l'aide de communautaire de la de
militaire et comme ça et quand on se
promène à Arria on voit énormément de de
drapeaux Ukrainiens dans les rues vous
allez venir annoncé rétablir le service
militaire obligatoire pour les hommes
alors depuis qu'elle faisait partie de
l'OTAN ça avait été supprimé
comment on réagit les laitons à cette
annonce
je pense que les laiton réagit
avec vêtements
c'est à dire tout le monde ont compris
que maintenant c'est le période de
comment dire real politique
c'est à dire c'est le période de
politique de force de de fort
et ce n'est pas justement le
fort diplomatique qui joue le rôle c'est
le rôle de chaque habitant
chaque citoyen
dans toutes les pays qui peut faire les
meilleurs pour défendre l'Europe pour
défendre les valeurs de l'Europe et
défendre son pays c'est à dire
quand même avec l'armée dans dans les
mains
parce que la Russe il joue ils ont cassé
toutes les règles toutes les lois
internationales le
les actions criminales ce sont les plus
grands actions criminales dans le monde
qui qui qui qu'on peut imaginer
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'étais en avril
déjà au bout de radian qui
j'ai vu avec mes yeux qu'est-ce qui se
passe là-bas j'ai beaucoup des amis il y
a des amis qui sont tués mes amis
coloniaux les tragédies dans les
familles avec les enfants c'est on ne
peut pas imaginer qu'est-ce qui se passe
là-bas donc on doit faire tous pour pour
faire les victoires pour le créer pour
pour faire que la ruse perde cette cette
guerre
et pour établir le
position et le situation on y avec
l'ocraine je pense que maintenant cette
pays le pays donc le drapeau de
l'Ukraine ce n'est pas justement le
drapeau de un pays c'est le drapeau de
courage c'est le drapeau de valeur et
maintenant
la Lettonie a fait
la route de l'Union européenne de
l'automne
c'était facile si on met un autre par le
créne maintenant il fait cette route
avec le sang avec les gens qui qui vient
à la gare et il donne sa vie pour
changer le crâne pour libérer le cahier
de l'Union soviétique est de gagner
l'indépendance et sa place à l'Union
européenne dans l'Europe et peut-être
aussi dans l'automne les dernières
choses que qu'est-ce qui se passe en
fait
on a gagné l'indépendance après
l'occupation de de Lucie de l'Union
soviétique mais on sait que justement
maintenant
l'Union soviétique
est fini ce n'était pas fini dans le
moment quand on a gagné l'indépendance
30 ans avant c'est c'est la fin de
l'Union soviétique justement maman et
c'est cette fin est très dure très
[Musique]
n'est pas facile et les gens qui vit
dans l'architecture et de système de
pensée dans dans le système de de
l'Union soviétique il ne veut pas
changer ça et
c'est la bataille c'est la guerre
maintenant pour actuellement tu es
l'Union soviétique dans les têtes est
finie tout ça
mais le poids de l'histoire et après ça
on tousse on pouvait regarder dans la
dans l'avenir et et
déjà
faire la vie dans l'avenir après tout ça
cette guerre elle a également des
conséquences économiques très très
fortes avec l'inflation en France elle a
atteint 6% chez vous en Lettonie elle a
atteint 21% comment est-ce que vous
faites pour tenir ce choc économique
voilà on connaît que la liberté et n'est
pas gratuit free de mes notes for free
c'est c'est mieux en anglais dire on
connaît que on paye maintenant
cette
paiement de liberté ça coûte beaucoup
ont essayé de faire la Lettonie Lettonie
Estonie ont payé plus beaucoup que les
autres on connaisse parce que toutes les
routes de
transit tout tout ça et arrêter l'import
de ressources de Russie arrêté et c'est
bien parce que on ne veut pas financer
les
morts de de des enfants
ukrainiens
mais bien sûr ont essayé de compenser
les les problèmes économiques pour le
citoyen de Lettonie on essaye de changer
l'économie changer les canines et faire
plus durable indépendant
faire ouvrir nouvelle possibilité
maintenant on va faire la ministre de
un environnement et
et
climat donc c'est le ministère de climat
énergie c'est-à-dire on concentre aussi
vers les vers les buts de France on sait
que Monsieur Macron a parlé beaucoup de
de
méthodes de économique énergie
comment dire ce stade
c'est à dire on va vers cette cette
merci beaucoup Edward d'avoir été avec
nous on a pu voir que vous parliez très
bien français comment est-ce que vous
l'avez appris j'ai étudié 12 ans lycée
français de Riga mais en fait j'essaye
de souvenirs comment on parler français
parce que en d'habitude j'ai parlé
anglais ou peut-être dans l'autre langue
et bien sûr le temps tout le temps mais
mais j'essaie d'utiliser chaque
possibilité chez Madame
l'ambassadeur et toutes les cartes pour
utiliser la langue française et je suis
francophone et aussi je c'est mon
plaisir de faire le coopération avec la
France et bien merci beaucoup d'avoir
une tonne de nous avoir reçu ici à la
Cima je rappelle que vous êtes le
nouveau président donc du Parlement
laiton merci beaucoup
[Musique]
la Lettonie compte selon l'Organisation
internationale de la Francophonie 20000
locuteurs français ça représente 1% de
la population ici faire rayonner la
culture française c'est la mission de
l'Institut français de Lettonie on en
parle tout de suite avec la directrice
Véronique du ce soir
bonjour Véronique dussa bonjour merci de
nous recevoir ici à l'Institut français
de Lettonie une institution qui fait
partie intégrante des services de
l'ambassade de France en Lettonie donc
elle est chargée votre objectif c'est de
faire rayonner la culture française dans
le pays l'Institut donc donne des cours
de français à commencer donc par ses
courses une langue plutôt appréciée des
laitons le français ou pas
oui tout à fait alors pour diverses
raisons et ce que j'essaie de faire
c'est de depuis mon Mandanda j'ai donc
je suis actuellement dans ma quatrième
année c'est de vraiment de diversifier
les motivations pour apprendre le
français donc beaucoup de nos apprenants
et qui sont souvent des apprenantes
c'est de c'est d'apprendre le français
pour le plaisir pour découvrir la
culture la
pour faire du tourisme en France et ce
que je voudrais faire c'est de
promouvoir la France et le français
comme une langue aussi qui permet
d'ouvrir des opportunités de travail de
pour venir en France pour étudier pour
travailler et pour multiplier les
échanges entre la France et la Lettonie
tonne et le français sont deux langues
assez différentes
c'est pas trop dur pour les détons
d'apprendre le français
alors c'est un peu difficile pour moi de
dire parce que je enfin je suis pas les
tonnes mais
enfin ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
la chose intéressante c'est qu'on a de
plus en plus de Primo débutant donc
il y a une appétence pour pour la langue
française pour commencer à apprendre la
langue française et je dirais que avec
la l'enseignement à distance on a on a
bien élargi notre public donc il y a une
c'est peut-être difficile de toute façon
l'apprentissage des langues ce n'est
jamais facile surtout si on se lance
dans une dans un apprentissage
sérieux et de un investissement sérieux
mais en tout cas il y a une appétence
alors sur le site de l'Institut français
de Lettonie on peut dire que vous
souhaitez mettre en valeur toutes les
facettes donc de l'excellence française
qu'est-ce que ça signifie
alors ça signifie c'est vraiment mon
objectif qui est celui aussi du
ministère bien évidemment enfin ce que
je suis diplomate de carrière donc c'est
vraiment l'objectif du ministère c'est
de faire briller la France dans les
différents domaines
c'est-à-dire que enfin bien évidemment
la culture parce que c'est quelque chose
qui est
reconnu c'est on va des Champs Élysées
jusqu'à
vraiment toute la diversité de la
culture française mais aussi de montrer
une France contemporaine donc en faisant
par exemple on a beaucoup investi dans
la réalité virtuelle dans ce que la
France
sait faire dans la réalité virtuelle on
a aussi ce qu'on essaie de ce qu'on
promet c'est aussi ce que la France fait
dans le domaine du débat d'idées donc
c'est vraiment les différentes facettes
la
physique quantique donc c'est c'est
vraiment toute la diversité de la
culture française et en particulier la
les choses qui sont peut-être moins
connues mais vraiment la culture la
France moderne la Lettonie c'est un pays
relativement peu connu en France
quels sont les Français qui vivent ici
alors je connais j'avoue que je connais
pas tous les Français qui vivent en
Lettonie
mais je sais que depuis pendant la
période du covid il y a beaucoup de
personnes on a on a vraiment augmenté la
Communauté française s'est accrue donc
les raisons
parmi les personnes que j'ai entendu
parler parce que ça c'est plutôt le
travail de du consulat donc de ma
collègue au consulat mais c'est alors ça
peut être des liens familiaux bien
évidemment ça il y a des gens qui se
sont installés parce que tout simplement
avec la période du covid et le travail à
distance la Lettonie c'est quand même
enfin c'est un pays que on peut
facilement travailler à distance donc il
y a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup de
raisons
le télétravail est assez était en tout
cas assez répandu et pour les Français
effectivement c'est un pays qui se
retrouve qui se trouve à une
à quelques quelques heures enfin très
peu d'heures de distance de Paris et il
y a une qualité de vie qui est qui est
incroyable et
donc enfin vous avez certainement vu
Riga beaucoup de parcs très agréable
alors parmi les missions de l'Institut
français Lettonie était aussi donc de
promouvoir l'enseignement supérieur
français auprès des étudiants laiton
vous pouvez donc accompagner ces
étudiants qui souhaitent et aller
étudier en France absolument absolument
ça c'est une démission essentielle qui
est plus une mission de l'ambassade plus
que de l'Institut français je vais pas
vous je vais pas vous embêter avec les
différenciations entre l'ambassade et
l'Institut mais effectivement
dans mon équipe j'ai un volontaire
international qui est chargé de la
promotion de la coopération
universitaire et de la Recherche et
notamment il est en charge de du
dispositif dit Campus France et qui
promeut les études en France alors ça
peut se faire donc en Lettonie il y a
deux salons de grands salons qui sont
organisés à au printemps et un à
l'automne en novembre et l'objectif
c'est de vraiment faire savoir faire
connaître les études en France et la
fréquentation est très bonne et puis par
ailleurs il y a une permanence qui est
organisée pour pour ceux qui veulent
s'informer de façon plus direct
enfin pour ça pour connaître les
dispositifs de d'enseignement du
français
enfin pardon en France et aussi
on est en train de développer alors sa
forte heureusement le la période du
covid est terminée donc
cela le volontaire international sera
aussi dans les écoles pour promouvoir
les études en France alors pour finir
j'aimerais parler aussi de cette
exposition que vous organisez en ce
moment elle s'appelle j'aime tout ce qui
est français ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter le concept
je pense que le nom de l'exposition
résume bien ce que
l'idée de ce qu'est cette exposition
c'est de trouver alors certainement vous
avez pu voir cette exposition donc il y
a à la fois les images de la France des
personnes qui se sont rendues en France
mais il y a aussi des points ou des
choses que les personnes retrouvent en
Lettonie et qui leur font penser à la
France donc c'est vraiment c'est l'idée
c'est de bâtir les ponts et c'est de
promouvoir encore une fois l'excellence
la qualité de la vie de la France et en
France et tout ce qui est voilà j'aime
tout ce qui est français et de montrer
donc les similitudes qu'il peut y avoir
aussi entre la Lettonie et la France
merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes la directrice de l'Institut
français de Lettonie et aussi la
conseillère de coopération et d'action
culturelle de l'ambassade
[Musique]
en 2022
Erasmus a fêté ses 35 ans le programme
européen a permis à 12 millions de
jeunes défectuer une mobilité et de
partir vivre dans un autre pays certains
Français comme Antoine Yaël ou Théo ont
fait le choix de la Lettonie en cours à
l'Académie des arts ou à l'université de
Lettonie il nous raconte leur expérience
pourquoi avoir fait un Erasmus à Riga en
Lettonie
[Musique]
dans un pays que je
ne connaissais pas donc Stockholm
pourquoi pas ça pourrait être
intéressant et ma mère m'a poussé à
trouver d'autres écoles au cas au
Stockholm ne prennent pas donc j'ai
cherché d'autres écoles grâce à un site
qui m'a permis de trouver d'autres
écoles d'art qui travaillent dans le
verre et ce qui donc m'a permis de
découvrir cette école ici tout d'abord
parce que moi j'ai toujours été très
intéressé par les pays de l'Est en
général voilà c'est le pays Baltics pas
exactement la même chose mais il y a
tous l'héritage de l'Union soviétique
etc moi ça m'a toujours intéressé et
puis c'est vrai que j'ai beaucoup de
beaucoup d'amis beaucoup de familles qui
sont partis en Espagne en Angleterre
même
Mexico et je me suis dit bon j'ai essayé
de trouver autre chose un petit peu plus
intéressante moi je suis un pur sudiste
donc je ne jure que par le soleil et
finalement regga c'est ça s'est présenté
un petit peu comme un bon juste milieu
ou ça coûtait pas trop cher parce que
maintenant nous les années à l'étranger
à l'Angleterre coûte très très cher qui
s'est sorti de l'Union européenne et les
pays scandinaves sont aussi très très
demandés et au niveau des prix c'est ça
montre très vite très haut et donc
finalement regga c'était un mélange un
petit peu entre une mentalité un petit
peu scandinave et un moyen de parler
anglais à un prix pas excessif
[Musique]
un quoi ressemble le quotidien
ma journée type c'est
disons de métro boulot dodo mais plutôt
à pied
je fais tout à pied ici parce que les
transports en commun c'est il coûte un
peu cher mais d'un autre côté j'en ai
pas vraiment besoin non plus
et je passe le une grande partie de ma
journée à l'école quand je le peux je
vais en cours le matin et la journée se
termine je dirais peut-être 16 heures et
après en général vu qu'on a des groupes
Erasmus sur WhatsApp et ce genre de
réseau et on se dit que quelqu'un qui
veut sortir boire une bière boire
quelque chose et tout et du coup en
général oui on se retrouve avec ceux qui
sont là etc et on se retrouve et ça
dépend des fois ça s'arrête tôt des fois
ça s'arrête pas et après moi j'ai aussi
la chance d'être dans un espèce de
d'immeuble de d'étudiants bon il y a pas
de pas de français pas trop d'Européens
c'est que des Ouzbeks des étudiants qui
viennent existants et du coup eux
m'emmenaient plus vu qu'il connaissent
bien Riga parce que en fait il parle
russe et ici 80% la population par le
russe et du coup ils m'ont emmené un peu
dans les dans les boîtes de nuit typique
de Riga on a on est mixé avec des
laitons dans les dans les cours donc ça
permet de rencontrer des locaux aussi
pour pour aller découvrir les places qui
sont qui sont cachés des touristes et
puis et puis sinon c'est tout on était
assez peu de cours on a une quinzaine
d'heures par semaine grand maximum et
c'est surtout beaucoup beaucoup de
voyages je sais que le train ici il
coûte un prix dérisoire enfin
si je veux traverser le pays pour aller
jusqu'à degafils par exemple
aller-retour je vais en avoir pour pour
15 euros pour pour 3 heures de train
aller et 3 heures de train retour et ça
c'est le paradis on peut bouger partout
dans la Lettonie en claquant du doigt on
a des vols pas chers pour aller pour
aller en Estonie en Lituanie en
Scandinavie
[Musique]
en quoi est-ce une expérience
enrichissante
[Musique]
et c'est vrai que du coup toutes ces
rencontres ça me fait voir différents
différentes façons de vivre et puis du
coup j'ai des contacts maintenant et
puis même j'ai déjà prévu de ah bah si
tu mets en France je t'héberge si je
viens te voir je t'héberge du coup ça
fait un réseau immense elle est
enrichissante par plusieurs par
plusieurs aspects tout d'abord en tant
qu'étudiant c'est c'est une expérience
qui est inouïe et qui est à faire parce
que on sort de notre zone de confort on
va à l'étranger on découvre quelque
chose de complètement nouveau découvre
une nouvelle culture on découvre aussi
une nouvelle façon d'enseigner des profs
qui qui enseignent une façon très
différente de la méthode de la méthode
française on découvre aussi des travaux
de groupe très différents on découvre
aussi d'autres étudiants qui viennent
d'un peu partout dans le monde donc on
découvre énormément de de nouvelles
choses sur le plan sur le plan culturel
c'est aussi évidemment hyper bénéfique
sur le plan linguistique parce que rien
que Harry gay ici on va pouvoir
progresser donc en anglais ça c'est
certain mais pour ceux qui apprennent le
Russe aussi c'est un moyen d'apprendre
le russe
un Erasmus un Riga en Lettonie vous
recommandez
[Musique]
découvrir une langue qui n'a absolument
rien à voir avec que ce soit le français
l'espagnol ou même le polonais ce genre
de pays et
l'architecture c'est peut être un c'est
la ville de Rega est extrêmement fournie
en architecture Art Nouveau et ne
serait-ce que découvrir de bâtiments
d'époque donc pas forcément historique
un peu abîmé mais toujours toujours
aussi bien décoré
ça peut être très intéressant si on est
mordu d'architecture comme moi
déjà la pâte est à 350 donc pour une
capitale c'est assez intéressant et
au-delà de Riga c'est bien connu pour vu
que c'est une très petite ville on peut
faire de bout en bout une demi-heure à
pied donc c'est vrai qu'on peut se
rendre partout allez rejoindre des
copains qu'on s'est fait la veille enfin
sans aucune difficulté si on veut
découvrir un petit peu la Scandinavie
mais on a pas énormément mais qu'on n'a
pas envie de dépenser des milliers
d'essai à Stockholm moi Oslo ou encore
elsinki c'est le juste milieu parfait on
a de la forêt partout on a
on a vraiment moyen de découvrir un
nouveau monde ouais c'est vraiment ça
pour moi c'est vraiment un monde à part
un petit coin d'Europe perdu loin des
touristes et qui
[Musique]
est juste apaisant et en même temps très
vivant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
zone Europe c'est terminé vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission en replay sur
notre site internet sur notre
application radio sensation et aussi sur
TV 78 bonne soirée à tous on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
numéro
[Musique]